[Música]
ah
argentina anunció que se abstendrá en la
elección del próximo presidente del
banco interamericano de desarrollo del
bid que tendrá lugar este fin de semana
tampoco presentará como candidato a
gustavo béliz secretario de asuntos
estratégicos del gobierno argentino todo
esto después de que fracasara su intento
por postergar la elección hasta marzo de
2021 después de las presidenciales de
noviembre en eeuu con la expectativa de
que si donald trump lo conseguido la
reelección
su sucesor retirará la candidatura de
mauricio clave el crown asesor de la
casa blanca y con espectativa entonces
de que un latinoamericano pudiera asumir
la presidencia del bid como es tradición
en el organismo esto no sucedió claro el
carbón continúa como candidato de la
casa blanca para ese rol y en estos días
el canciller argentino felipe solá
señaló que al llegar a ver cada una el
bid eeuu intentará usar el organismo
para tratar de dar batalla a la
influencia china en la región todo esto
en un contexto en que china se ha
convertido en el principal socio
comercial de argentina
[Música]
a finales de junio la ex presidenta de
costa rica laura chinchilla había
anunciado su postulación a la
presidencia del banco interamericano de
desarrrollo chinchilla la primera mujer
en ocupar la presidencia de su país
tenía también la aspiración de ser la
primera mujer presidenta de esa entidad
financiera por lo que promovió su
candidatura con el respaldo del gobierno
del presidente carlos alvarado sin
embargo la ex mandataria costarricense
anunció el 3 de septiembre que
renunciaría a sus aspiraciones tras
haber criticado el proceso de elección
chinchilla señaló que eeuu modifico
normas para inscribir a su candidato
mauricio claver carone se trata de una
regla no escrita pero que ha permanecido
vigente durante seis décadas que implica
que la presidencia sería ocupada por una
persona latinoamericana o caribeña y la
vicepresidencia por una de nacionalidad
estadounidense además la ex mandataria
costarricense había propuesto posponer
por seis meses la fecha de la elección
debido a la atención que requiere la
pandemia de coronavirus una petición
hecha también por la unión europea
no fue aceptada
[Música]
colombia es uno de los países junto a
eeuu el salvador guyana haití paraguay
bolivia o brasil que apoyan la única
candidatura del estadounidense mauricio
claver carone para presidir el banco
interamericano de desarrollo esto a
pesar de las presiones de países como
argentina que contaba con el apoyo de la
unión europea para haber postergado la
elección en colombia el presidente iván
duque fue firme en mantener la fecha
para este fin de semana alegando que es
necesario dar claridad a toda la región
en un momento tan complicado como el de
la pandemia la votación en washington
servirá para dar relevo al empresario
colombiano luis alberto moreno que ha
sido durante 15 años el líder del banco
cabe destacar por otra parte que después
de la votación la siguiente asamblea de
gobernadores del bid será en marzo de
2021 precisamente en barranquilla en el
atlántico colombiano fecha en la que la
asamblea parlamentaria
euro-latinoamericana pidió que se
celebrase la votación del presidente por
debido a la pandemia y también por ser
después de las elecciones
estadounidenses del 3 de noviembre
[Música]